the highest activity a human being can
attain
is learning for understanding
because to understand
is to be free
nothing in nature is random
a thing appears random only through the
incompleteness of our knowledge
pride is pleasure arising from a man's
thinking too highly of himself
those who know the true use of money
and regulate the measure of wealth
according to their needs
live contented with few things
i do not know how to teach philosophy
without becoming a disturbance of the
peace
no matter how thin you slice it
there will always be two sides
if you want the present to be different
from the past
study the past
everything excellent
is as difficult as it is rare
i have made a ceaseless effort not to
ridicule
not to be wailed
not to scorn human actions but to
understand them
the more clearly you understand yourself
and your emotions
the more you become a lover of what is
peace is not the absence of war
it is a virtue
a state of mind
a disposition of benevolence
confidence justice
when a man is prey to his emotions
he is not his own master
[Music]
what paul says about peter
tells us more about paul than about
peter
i have striven not to laugh at human
actions
not to weep at them
nor to hate them
but to understand them
[Music]
insofar as the mind sees things in their
eternal aspect
it participates in eternity
the endeavor to understand
is the first and only basis of virtue
emotion
which is suffering
ceases to be suffering as soon as we
form a clear and precise picture of it
there can be no hope without fear
and no fear without hope
in practical life we are compelled to
follow
what is most probable
in speculative thought we are compelled
to follow truth
a free man thinks of nothing less than
of death
and his wisdom is a meditation
not on death
but on life
none are more taken by the flattery than
the proud
who wish to be the first
and are not
we feel and experience ourselves to be
eternal
minds however
are conquered not by arms
but by love and nobility
he alone is free who lives with free
consent
under the entire guidance of reason
[Music]
only in relation to our imagination
can things be called beautiful or ugly
well ordered or confused
the only way to avoid death is to make
art
blessedness is not the reward of virtue
but virtue itself
nature offers nothing that can be called
this man's rather than in others
but under nature everything belongs to
all
a poor man is better than a rich man
because he has a clear
conscience a man is obliged to cry only
in one case
from happiness
do not lend money to relatives because
you will lose both
[Music]
only a fool craves money
a smart one craves opportunities
i call him freedom who is led solely by
reason
[Music]
the mind of god is all the mentality
that is scattered over space and time
the diffused consciousness that animates
the world
reason is no match for passion
self-preservation is the primary and
only foundation of virtue